[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bob kemp
he's a host of the sports zone on our
great affiliate kdus in arizona and he
joins us now bob your reaction when you
first saw this story and the language in
the contract
almost sprained my neck shaking my head
um
what uh
what's going on here um you know there's
been some interesting decision making by
the quarterback in three seasons here
but uh
obviously this has been an issue or this
would not be any kind of language of any
contract and something i've never heard
of before let's go back to last year the
way the season ended
that uh you know they started out 7-0
and then they flamed out here
how much of the blame
uh did kyler murray shoulder
plenty i mean certainly it was an issue
i mean they were cruising along and you
know obviously they had some injuries
murray got hurt and then obviously
in his leg he suffered a leg injury and
he did not score a rushing touchdown
after that leg injury when he came back
from the injury
and obviously deandre hopkins was
injured and missed the you know seven of
the last eight game or eight i guess it
was the last eight games of the season
and uh combination of that and
defensively you know jj watt who got off
to a great start was injured and didn't
play the rest of the regular season he
tried to come back and play in the
postseason game
against the rams and that game was
obviously a disaster in all fronts
including murray who was you know had
the infamous uh you know two yard pick
six and just a just a mindless play by
him but yeah he's certainly a lot of the
responsibilities on the quarterback and
that's just the way the world works
especially if you're getting 46.1
billion dollars annually which will be
the case starting this year
but i'm trying to understand uh
the cliff kingsbury's role as the head
coach here
that these are things that you're sort
of taught when you come in and usually
there's a veteran quarterback to help
you like what role does cliff kingsbury
play in saying to kyler
we
need to prepare better like this
language embarrasses kyler murray i mean
embarrasses arizona too but i would
think a coach should be able to say your
quarterback
let's prepare better i need to you know
how do we make this
um a strong suit for you not a weakness
i have no idea how to answer that
question i mean it's amazing that it is
a question to me um
you know it's uh
certainly i think there's a you know
certainly kingsbury deserves uh you know
some
you know there's some responsibility on
him here too but uh yeah if you have a
quarterback that apparently isn't going
to
you know do uh you know study like most
quarterbacks if pretty close not to all
quarterbacks as far as opponents and so
forth
i'm not sure what you can really do if
the quarterback or the the player
involved is uh not willing to put in the
time and
you know they're going to make and put
in the time to some extent because you
know they can monitor the computer and
whatever so it's just an inexplicable
situation
we're talking to bob kemp host of the
sports zone the show that follows ours
on our arizona affiliate kd us what do
you think the local reaction is going to
be when you uh start your show in a
couple hours
i think it's going to be i think the
local reaction is just to be kind of
piling on to what has already occurred
you know we i mentioned the playoff game
last year at the end and you know that
was about as bad at performance from the
quarterback and it wasn't all him it was
certainly a team effort
the meltdown against the rams early the
no chance to win almost type of game
against the rams in the postseason and
they finally got to the postseason for
the first time in several years and
couldn't that couldn't have gone any
worse and
you know they needed some good will here
and yeah the off-season negotiation
was not exactly a smooth ride i mean
team murray went out as far as the money
at the end
but you know scrubbing the cardinals
from the social media
and then you have the
back and forth of oh i'm you know we're
good you know no problem with the
cardinals la dee da and
you know it's not a bit it's not been
the uh
exactly uh the way that uh i think a pr
person would draw this up for the for
the player here no
you should be celebrating something like
this instead uh you know we're
we're criticizing it bob thanks for
joining us uh we appreciate your time
my pleasure thank you bob kim host of
the sports zone follows ours arizona
affiliate kdus should be an easy show
there for bob